oh I got for this guy Dwight Schrute in
the building this is Ryan the new temp
so nice to meet you introduce yourself
people like Dwight Schrute assistant
regional manager assistant to the
regional manager so great tell him about
the the Kung Fu and the car and
everything uh yeah I got a 78 to 80 Z I
bought it for 1,200 fixed rips now worth
three grand is His Prophet
yeah new engine suspension I got Rhys
brackets and photos hold on hold on
judges in session what is the problem
here put my stuff in jello again that's
real professional Thanks the third time
it wasn't funny the first time zai Jian
it's ok here but people sometimes take
advantage because it's so relaxed I'm a
volunteer sheriff's deputy on the
weekends and you cannot screw around
there it's sort of one of the rules
it's my staple no no no do not take it
out if to eat it out of there because
there are starving people in the world
and which I hate and it is a waste of
that kind okay you know what you can be
a witness can you reprimand him please
how do you know it was me it's always
you are you gonna discipline him or not
Oh discipline kinky all right here's the
deal you guys
think about a practical joke is that you
have to know when to start as well as
when to stop yeah and yeah and Jim now
is the time to stop putting Dwight's
personal effects into jello okay
Dwight I'm sorry because I've always
been your biggest flan you should have
put him in custardy oh that's great I
guess what I'm most concerned with is
damage to company property that's all
putting put Dean that's right I think
you